hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so very quickly
i'm professional trader and i do some
videos about technical analysis
to show you guys the different
techniques that i use to make my trades
but in this video i want to talk about
something that is a bit different but as
much as important as technical analysis
this is risk management let's get into
it
[Music]
so risk management uh to me is
let's call it golden rule number one is
like a set of rules that i want to
show you guys that you need to follow if
you want to be profitable in the long
run
so very quickly let me tell you a story
to show you guys
how much this is important so the
kind of best technical trader i know uh
he's an italian guy
a bit younger than me uh let's call him
giuseppe for
for the story it's not his real name but
i don't want to
give his identity you know uh so
giuseppe
was uh to be honest a genius like
he was the kind of guy that could tell
you uh
where the market would be for example in
two hours so he was not always right of
course
but quite often you know the probability
to know where the market is gonna be for
example in two hours is close to zero
and sometimes this guy was giving you
the answer very precisely
because like his tools the environment
he was working in
was very efficient at least for him he
knew how to
associate the different uh indicators he
was using
and he was a beast you know seriously he
he you know
all the traders they were often calling
him like hey giuseppe can you
tell me uh for example where do you see
this
uh index or this currency trading
i don't know tomorrow or whatever and
giuseppe was just coming and saying hey
guys
like what i see is that most likely this
could happen you have a resistance here
uh so the market could get rejected and
then come back it usually takes like
another few hours blah blah blah
and it was just impressive he
he was helping us really to generate a
lot of
money um he was very precious and
he knew that he knew that he was good so
he was like all right
why wouldn't i do some uh pa
which is personal account trading um
and so he started to trade pm so at the
beginning he was trading just a little
bit
uh but actually he's the kind of guy
that was aiming at the moon you know he
wanted to do something that people would
remember
um and actually he did but not for the
good reasons
and you're gonna you're gonna see why so
he
started to trade a bit bigger amounts
and and then there was this trade
that he he was like very short you know
he was like
right i have a lot of uh support um
signals at this level so i know there's
going to be a lot of liquidity if the
market comes here
so i want to buy a very massive position
at this level
and he set up his stop loss and his
target was a nice risk reward
so around like three or four something
like this so very quickly for those who
don't know the risk reward
is how much you can win divided by how
much you are ready to lose
uh it's important to have a risk reward
between three
and five to eight at least this is how i
like to have it but above three is very
important
so his risk reward was around three or
four whatever
and so he enters his position the market
comes to the level he wants to buy he
buys
a lot he he put a lot of money and
it goes well it rebounds exactly how he
predicted it
and he starts to to be profitable um
and then few days later there is an
announcement by the bank of japan you
know the boj
uh it was like few years ago and it was
crowded saying like uh i don't know
something about quantitative easing
whatever
and the market didn't like it so it
dropped heavily
uh and i look at the market i remember
where where was his stop-loss and then
it just rebounds just before he stopped
us it was beautiful
you know uh it was perfect and it was
something like minus two percent
with like in one hour and a few hours
after it was like plus five
so basically up three on the day um
so i look at him i say yo man you're
coming back from the dead
and he he's not replying he looks like a
ghost
you know so i understand something is
wrong and he comes to me
he looks at me and he say i just lost
everything so i'm like how is that
possible he says i don't know
so then you know he talks to me about
his train
and and he told he tells me yeah i just
got stopped by the broker so i'm like
how much money you had and we compute
everything and i'm like yeah but this is
normal that you got stopped you know
because you were probably below the
maintenance margin
and he was not aware that the
maintenance margin was different from
zero
so very quickly you know you have a lot
of margin requirements when you trade
through a broker like
interactive broker saxo bank which are
the two best brokers for me for personal
training
but whatever and you need to have some
amount on
some money on your account to keep your
position and this amount of money is not
zero
so when you compute your stop loss uh
you need to
to to keep in mind that before you lose
everything
the broker is going to stop your
position and this is what happened to
him
and of course afterwards what happened
the nikkei was just like going up every
day
and it's it has reached his target so
his trade was a winner
you know he would have made a lot of
money he would have been
rich very quickly but instead of that
he lost everything he lost the bonus he
made the year before
he lost the money he actually
accumulated in his account by doing his
like small
good trades um so
and so basically he learned the hard way
that
you have some margin requirements and
that you need
not to over invest so if we go
through giuseppe's story together we can
kind of identify what mistakes he did
and he did a lot
the number one mistake it's that he
didn't know
about the rules of the instruments he
was training
uh it was futures and he didn't know
about the margins requirements so this
is very important
to know about so very quickly the
initial margin
is the minimum amount you need to have
on your account to enter trade
then the maintenance margin is the
amount below
which your the broker is going to stop
your position and it's very different
from zero so you guys need to be aware
of it
please go check it out before doing a
trade and then you have the variation
margin which is the money you need to
top up
to stay in the trade after margin
violation
the second mistake he did is that he had
too much leverage
or he was over invested this comes back
to the same thing
um so it's very important to calibrate
the the your initial investment
uh in order not to lose everything if
things go wrong
you know so even if like um
he didn't got stopped by the broker but
just his stop-loss he would have lost
almost everything
so you know anyways his trade was too
risky too aggressive
uh you cannot let this happen you cannot
get wiped out and lose everything
uh just because you were wrong once you
know training is not about
about being always wrong is about being
more
right than wrong it's about expected
gains and probabilities
so you know and for example uh
in banks or hedge funds or any big
institutions
i can tell you that the number of uh
people working in the risk management
teams
is as big as the number of traders
roughly you know
and this is not because they like to
burn cash this is because
this is necessary you need to have a
proper structure of risk management
that you know they're going to study
every scenario they're going to study
the maximum loss you can do it's called
the var
and stuff like this and then they're
going to calibrate some limits that you
cannot
exceed so the investment for retail
investors it would come to the initial
investment
that you can make that you can have the
position you can bear
uh before they they stop you you get
stopped by your own bank before
before being stopped by the exchange you
know so basically
uh if it is very important to follow
some rules
to be successful in the long run so uh
you are not a professional investor
you are not a bank but you you need to
follow
some steps in your risk management in
order to be successful
and i'm gonna tell you what steps there
are
so the number one rule in risk
management
is to define your time horizon uh type
of trading all right so you can be a
scalper
so it's like few hours you can be a day
trader like you close your position
before the end of the day
you can be a swing trader weeks month
time horizon
or long term investor which is called
position trading
so this is the first thing you need to
know to know what kind of training you
want to do
then you need to select uh your entry
level
stop loss and target properly depending
on what kind of training you want to do
if you want to do long term investment
this is fine you can do without a stop
loss
but if you do all the other kind of
trading which is like shorter term
uh you need to have a stop loss
otherwise you're going to get stopped by
the exchange or by the broker
as giuseppe has been
[Music]
and once you have so you need to select
uh
your entry level stop loss and target
following
a risk reward above three so once again
the risk reward is the money you want to
make
divided by the money you want to lose so
for example if you have a risk reward
equal to three
it means that if you are right only 25
percent of the time
you are not losing money which is very
important guys not to lose money and 25
percent of the time is not that
complicated
or not right um so once you have defined
your uh entry level stop loss and
targets
you need to decide about the kind of
instruments you're going to use to make
a strategy
to know the rules about those
instruments and to know the leverage
very important and depending on the
leverage you need
to choose very carefully your initial
investment
all right so this is the most important
thing do not over
invest you always need to keep at least
when you compute your your levels to
make sure you're gonna have at least
half of your capital on your account if
things
go wrong the worst uh case scenario
needs to be a scenario where you're only
going to lose 50 percent of your capital
if gzp
has uh if gzp had followed this rule
uh he would have been reached today once
again
instead of that he lost everything so
guys very important
do not over invest so i hope the story
and all the set of
rules that to me are very important of a
proper risk management
are going to help you guys to make your
trades properly
so if you enjoyed this video please hit
the like button and the subscribe button
and i'm gonna do very soon uh the golden
rule number two
which is to have discipline all right
stay close to shaw see you guys